okay so we've got the little I guess
we'll call it internal housekeeping to
do here Pat there's a few things I
wanted to check in with the audience
about one is I mentioned a couple weeks
ago that we are now again auditioning
new music for the program over the years
the music on the show has evolved we got
away from using copy written music that
we didn't have rights to use because the
show was getting big enough that we sort
of were at risk of having copyright
issues as a result of that right now the
music on the show is by a longtime
viewer who goes by the handle curtly J
and some people like the music some
people don't like the music that's
always been the case and I mentioned
that we're now starting to look at
switching it up right making us some
changes to the music as we always do not
because we don't love currently J and
his music but merely because we like to
rotate the music over time to keep a
fresh sound and a week or two ago I
mentioned that there is a song from an
artist and Pat thinks it's funny
whenever I say this I think it's
pronounced chousen but it might be
chosen I'm not exactly sure and this is
a song called contemporary American that
includes a sample of me right after a
sample of Howard Dean here's a reminder
this is sort of like option one for a
new theme song for the show
okay so that's one option all right I
have a couple options to present to you
in addition to that another possibility
is from art Flores and this is it starts
a little slow it's a totally different
sound it's specifically for the David
Pakman show
if we want it let's take a listen to it
[Music]
right
so anyway also some samples in it
totally different sound I I just am
unsure I'm just not good at this type of
thing and figuring out what's good for
the show I like that a little heavy on
the distortion yes holding that down a
little bit we can even ask art if this
is custom for us to do it just with a
slightly less distorted guitar track
that's a possibility then I've also
mentioned to give you a couple other
options that Stuber aux was the bassist
for Matisyahu for dub trio he's worked
with 50 cent Tupac tons of people he is
a friend of the show and a friend of
mine and he said we can use anything we
want from dub trio on the show again
totally different sound I'd be inclined
to use something from the 2004 album
called exploring the dangers here's one
possible track we could use
[Music]
okay and one other possibility another
track from the same album that maybe
people like take a listen okay so what
do people think do we use any of these
for do we keep things the way they are
do we keep taking new submissions from
people in the audience I don't know I
don't know and I think all of these
could work it's just I'm clueless about
everything and I regularly make horrible
decisions for the show so I'm no I'm
kidding but I am coming to the audience
because I don't really know what the
right sound is for us yeah I don't know
you already turned down my suggestion of
a acoustic folk pop song by yours truly
so and didn't you also want me to
consider using uh the itsy-bitsy spider
because you're like a big itsy-bitsy guy
aren't you but yeah
you were thinking of like a dubstep
version of itsy-bitsy sounds like two or
three have been into that stuff yeah
yeah and I just don't know that that's
the right direction but I told Pat to
add it to the list just so he wouldn't
you know you'll put off by it but let me
know okay if do any of these four make
sense to you are these terrible options
let me know and then we will eventually
make a decision